chrissy teigen maybe maybe the baby you
are being honored with the giving tree'
award tonight at the heads of 2019 baby
- baby gala talk about why that's
important to you what it means - it's
it's incredible because I feel like so
many people here know about this
organization and to ask - I've never had
I even told yes I was like I didn't I
knew I was being awarded but I didn't
know my name was like on the award I
thought it cuz a lot of my awards are
very silly and like best mac and cheese
are like best hot chip eater or
something really best mac and cheese
what's your secret the best mac and
cheese against john at least even i
don't really believe it anymore i was
very pregnant at the time and but yeah
my awards are silly and and then you get
to come be honored for something like
this and i didn't understand the
magnitude of it really i've been in one
of these events in the past and i was
very pregnant so i didn't get to enjoy
myself so i am enjoying myself tonight
and it's just it's nice hopefully we can
raise a ton of money for a ton of
children here and and have a good time
yeah it's absolutely going to a great
cause now you posted earlier about baby
miles transitioning from from a baby to
a toddler
[Music]
it's so much fun because there are baby
people and their toddler people there
are people that love a tiny little baby
but I need action
I need chaos I need them to talk back I
need them to I want to teach them
lessons and it's just it's so much fun
and yeah it was if there's any week that
he changed it's this week and he is just
talking not really talking but he's
talking so much and saying thank you and
saying mommy and and really knowing who
you are I know it sounds silly if you
don't have kids
but they say mama dad all the time but
it's weird when they know that you're
the mama and you're the daddy and you're
that it's just different and it's
beautiful now are your children a fan of
Kidz Bop music by any chance oh my god
do you see that video they are not in we
did on actually the lullabies I forget
what it's called but there's something
lullabies rocket rockabyebaby
rocket baby lullabies so it's like Kanye
they have like the Beatles and Duran
Duran like they have so many different
ones and I loved those but they loved
Lunas like a big ariana grande fan so
yes we're gonna go to our show and so
it's her first like other than John but
it's her first show so I know Kidz Bop
changed some of the lyrics to John's
John's song all of me from Kidz Bop
change it from love your curves love
your curves and all your edges to all
your words and all your edges how do you
feel about that I mean it makes sense
I'm down I'm obviously down for a lyric
change well speaking of lyric change how
about Sharon Osbourne giving all the
flack about the baby it's cold outside
and the thing is to change an innocent
lyric to its what is it your mind and
your body
Sharon's always gonna have something to
say it's her job so I remember those
days of getting to talk for money it was
very fun
[Music]